getting close to our Paleolithic
ancestors has helped to give svante
herbo his moment in history
the Swedish geneticist was handed
flowers and received congratulations
from his colleagues at the Max Planck
Institute in Leipzig Germany after being
named the 113th Nobel Prize winner in
physiology or medicine in his hometown
of Stockholm well under many years this
is my first thought was that this was a
sophisticated joke by my colleagues but
then it sounded a little too convincing
so I accepted that it was true it's
particularly fulfilling because it
started as a hobby doing something I
loved 30 years ago and for a long time
this research was seen as a bit of a
curiosity and now I think it's really
arrived as a serious research topic with
many different groups now working on it
purbo is credited with transforming the
study of human Origins he pioneered the
examination of DNA sequences from
archaeological and paleontological
remains to bridge the gap between
ourselves as Homo sapiens and our
extinct ancestors the Neanderthals
because of his discoveries we're able to
understand what makes us different and
unique from these close relatives
neanderthals were living in Europe over
a half a million years ago we Homo
sapiens came out of Africa about 75 000
years ago we mixed with neanderthals in
the Middle East we now know that we Homo
sapiens carry about one to two percent
of DNA from neanderthals we know that
from his work not content with bringing
neanderthals into the present purbo also
discovered another even older race the
Denise Evans thanks to DNA from a 40 000
year old bone found in a cave in Siberia
perbo's discovery of the denisovans then
led to evidence that they had mixed with
neanderthals Pebble was then able to
show that there's a little bit of
denisovan in all of us as well how about
seems to be the beneficiary of good
genes himself his father Suna Bergstrom
won a Nobel Prize in medicine in 1982.
what this Swedish scientist passes on to
the next generation is a better
understanding of the generations that
came a very long time before
Al Jazeera Stockholm